and Jen is the perfect example I would
not be surprised that he will eat his
own children
Jen my name mosad I'm with pills making
movie
film
yes did you guys know the prophet peace
be upon him
said PE upon him said the one who gives
a s his will be sh on and we're here
every Friday and Sunday doing da to many
people aldah seven Shas two weeks
ago two Shas last week two Shas last
week you can support this brother and
sisters with the material alhamdulillah
some of them we pay for some of them
aldah we get for free as you guys
donated to the Salah plus project Al
hamdah brothers and sisters if you can
donate whatever you can it will help our
operations to have a cameraman an
editing team and some of the brothers
who come and dedicate their time and
effort give in the link is in the
description box
below brothers and sisters and dear
friends get your popcorns ready get your
Chris those nachos that salsa sauce all
that thing please the son of Hamas no no
Bor
yeah come on when on P Morgan show
really I like and he's he's defending
Israel he said I like Israel really it's
very nice can't wait okay so here's the
discussion let's see his compelling
arguments cuz he's a very intelligent
guy I ACC is very high okay let's see
let's see I'm interested stretching once
what so-called Palestinians drop their
violent uh approach to the problem and
accept Israel's right to exist in that
region then we can talk about things but
to really water it down and say that
this is a conspiracy uh people like Jen
they are living in a conspiracy theory
alternative reality we tell them that
this war that's in started in Gaza is a
very dirty war he weaponized civilians
only to get sympathy of people like Jun
and many others PE many others around
the globe this many other people many
other peoples yes I like Pierce Morgan
very much he's
nice others around the this is the most
destructive weapon in the hands of Hamas
and millions around the world World fell
into this trap so as long as we Empower
Hamas more children are going to die and
if we don't remove Hamas from Power if
we don't remove the ayat from Power then
this endless uh and vicious cycle of
violence will continue for eternity it's
as simple as that but of course in the
meantime we are aware we are aware of
the suffering of the children the
children of Gaza were
born the the children
I like the children they are nice how
much one second one second one second
this the here what's the
children what what the hell what H is
about Allah is Allah him with his own
tongue you flipping children you're a
shield Arab they weren't born innocent
they were not born Palestinians then
they had been indoctrinated to hate they
have been IND indoctrinated to blame
Israel as Jen right now he has been
blaming Israel since the beginning of
the war but now he sees the defeat of
Hamas so now he's changing his tone a
little bit his attitude and I like his
clever he very clever Palestinian he's
the perfect example of a Palestinian by
the way Jen just right there because
Palestinian is not limited to Gaza
Palestinian is a syndrome it's a mental
illness it's a universal phen
and Jen is the perfect example and if he
gets hungry eventually I would not be
surprised that he will eat his own
children all I heard was all I heard was
a chen a my name mad I'm with bills
making movie
film yes and I thought I thought it's
good he's giving his him a chance on his
movie film bro this Bora like seven I
think this is Bor at normally it's like
2.0 this is Bor at 0.5 bro he just Bor
at rendering not only that what has Jen
eaten his children got to do with
anything why did he just randomly say if
Jen could he would his own
children I would not be surprised that
he will eat his own children so that's
his that's his argument that Chen is
going to eat his children children
children sorry sorry my bad my bad BR
what's that got it's just so bizarre
it's like M Tyson in a fight saying yeah
I'm Alexander I'm the greatest I'm going
eat your children it's just so out of
nowhere bro but you're not going to get
this because you're aama supporter yeah
you you don't understand implicitly what
he's saying is free the hostages uh I
have a right to self-defense children
and yakim these are children his three
main arguments I mean this guy you
cannot make it we can we could not make
this video serious guys int isn't I mean
he speaks for himself's he's his
absolute he can't speak proper
English Okay as you can see this is the
best he's Bor this is the that Israel
have to offer yeah exactly
from Grand what's old pert in epon
Islands yeah the Defenders of Epstein
and Harvey Weinstein and you know um
talking good of PD that desit guy uh I
mean that's that's what they're offering
who else who else are they bring to
Jordan Peterson child who Who's Crying
in every other video Yeah depressed may
Allah make him more depressed in who who
who else is there who's no one no one
everyone they have is either molesting
children killing them or children eat
your
children brother sisters hope you
enjoyed that it was just a little sniff
just for it will make your day inshah
you can't take this clown seriously may
Allah expose him in this life and here
after selling um his people for a couple
of pounds
Alum and to all the children that are
listening very
nice make sure you like subscribe and
free
Palestine yeah like this